good morning looks like things are  improving here's a live look at a crash  over in the spring valley area  metro police blocking all westbound  lanes of tropicana right after decatur  and there you see a person walking in  the  cruise here the the cruiser is blocking  all westbound lanes it's a report of an  injury crash  serious enough to close all westbound  lanes of tropicana right after decatur  so let's go to the maps and give you a  detour just go ahead and take hacienda  instead for you to  keep traveling westbound the rest of the  highway system  marching along okay except if you're on  u.s 95  the ongoing roadwork here slowing out  slowing down the drivers heading  northbound from the east over to  downtown